Google I O is this week and I'm sharing
a recap of generative AI announcements
generative AI support and vertex AI is
now available in public preview access
Palm our language model via API or
customize an experiment with it in
generative AI Studio Plus we announced
three New Foundation models in vertex AI
Kodi is a code generation model Imogen
is a text to image model and Chirp is a
speech to text Foundation model allowing
you to engage inclusively across
languages we also announced embeddings
for text and images you can build
recommendation engines classifiers and
other sophisticated apps based on
semantic understandings of text or
vector representations of images all
with blazing fast speed and improved
search quality and lastly reinforcement
learning from Human feedback adds to
verstex ai's prompt tuning fine tuning
and prompt design capabilities letting
you incorporate human feedback so you
can customize and improve model
performance we can't wait to see what
you build check out the link in our
description to learn more and take a
deeper dive into all the generative AI
announcements from IO